so now jesse lee's  approaching a crosswalk sometimes  traffic gets going pretty fast here and  he looks like he's just going to step  right into it car slams on its brakes  car behind it slams into that car  you're running from your from your uh  what you've been doing for 31 years  there it is  god and jesse lee doesn't even react to  the car wreck he causes  jesse's so upset that he uh tried to  cross the street before he should have  and caused these cars to stop and bash  and back and that's pretty serious  damage  so that's because um what a situation i  now have  video proof more so than before  tell me about you sleeping with your  brother's wife so quite a scene there  folks